SEBASTIAN: "Geil! Es hat funktioniert!"
Sebastian liebt sie, wir lieben sie und die Industrie erst recht:
Gepuffte Snacks! Denn in ihnen steckt ordentlich heiße Luft, die die Kasse klingeln lässt.
500 Prozent Preisaufschlag sind damit drin.
Wir zeigen, wie gesund die Snacks wirklich sind und wie der Puff-Trick funktioniert.
Ob Quinoa oder Amaranth, als Müsli oder in der Waffel -  überall finden wir gepuffte Körner.
Besonders deutlich wird der Preisunterschied allerdings beim Reis.
Das Naturprodukt kostet knapp 3 Euro pro Kilo, die gepuffte Version hingegen fast 17 Euro pro Kilo.
Möglich macht das ein
explosiver Trick und wie der funktioniert, weiß nur einer:
Sebastian Lege
SEBASTIAN: "Jetzt knallt's gleich richtig!"
Der Produktentwickler kennt die Tricks der Industrie, denn er hat sie mit erfunden.
SEBASTIAN: "Wir haben eine selbstgebaute Puff-Kanone.
Alles was stärkehaltig ist, noch ein bisschen Wasser enthält, also Restfeuchtigkeit, lässt sich super aufpuffen."
Und das funktioniert so: Die Körner werden mit etwas Wasser auf bis zu 300 Grad erhitzt.
Dadurch entwickelt sich ein
heißer Dampf, der die weichen Körner zusammendrückt.
Wird der Druck schlagartig aus der Kanone entladen
pufft die Stärke im Korn auf und wir erhalten fertigen Puffreis.
Also Körner und Wasser in die Trommel und los geht's!
Oder fehlt noch etwas, Sebastian?
Ganz wichtig: eine Lederdichtung, denn es darf er vorher kein Druck verloren gehen,
damit beim schlagartigen Befreien auch alles aufplatzt.
In seiner Kanone wird Sebastian gleich bis zu 35 bar erzeugen.
Wir werden das noch häufiger sagen, aber bitte macht das nicht zu Hause nach!
SEBASTIAN: "Ja geil! Da sind sie: die gepufften Reiskörner. Sauber!"
SEBASTIAN: "Das Ergebnis ist akzeptabel. Ich freu mich!"
Da bist du nicht allein, Sebastian. Auch für die
Industrie ist die Technik ein echt
profitabler Glücksgriff, denn mit einem
Schlag lassen sich die Körner auf das
Zehnfache ihrer ursprünglichen Größe aufpuffen.
Für eine Packung Reiswaffel braucht man so nur noch gut 200 Reiskörner
oder wie die Industrie sagt: leider geil.
Aus einer Packung Naturreis werden gepufft zehn Packungen.
Et voilà: eine
Preissteigerung von 500 Prozent!
Aber warte mal: Zerstört die Explosion nicht wichtige Inhaltsstoffe?
Ja! Unsere Laboruntersuchungen zeigen ein klares Ergebnis:
Das Vitamin-B1 und die wichtige Folsäure in den Reiskörnern gehen deutlich verloren.
Das gilt übrigens auch für gepufften Quinoa, Buchweizen oder Dinkel.
Doch das größere Problem liegt woanders.
Oft werden den gepufften Körnern Honig, Zucker und Schokolade zugesetzt.
Aus den scheinbar gesunden Snacks werden wahre Kalorienbomben.
Die Luftnummern aus
der Puff-Kanone schmecken so zwar knusprig-fein,
doch für diesen Spaß zahlen wir ordentlich drauf.
Mehr Tricks, Checks und Duelle aus der Welt der Lebensmittel
findet ihr auf unserem Kanal ZDFbesseresser.